problema número 71 wife acciones
equivalente a 3 x / 5 / x entre 4 + x
entre 2 bueno comencemos desarrollando
el denominador vamos a reescribir lo va
a ser 3x entre 5
en 35
y esto va a estar dividido entre que
bueno vamos a buscar el común
denominador de estos dos que luce como
que va a ser 4 entonces el común
denominador va a ser 4
entonces x entre 4 pues va a ser aquí
igual está x se conserva x
ahora tenemos x entre 2
tenemos 2x entre 4 pues lo podemos
escribir aquí es lo mismo que x entre 2
así que aquí sería 2x entre 4 y x2 x va
a ser igual
3x en 35 entre
3 x entre 4
cuando tenemos fracciones que se dividen
esto es lo mismo que multiplicar esto el
numerador por el recíproco o el inverso
del denominador así que esto es igual a
3 equis entre 5
por 4 entre 13 x
estas casas se cancelan nos queda que
esto es igual a cuatro quintos qué
curioso nos quedó una fracción si en el
componente x
ahora pasemos al siguiente problema
el siguiente problema nos dice
un farmacéutico mezcló una solución
salina del 10% con otra solución salina
del 15% para obtener 100 mililitros de
solución salina del 12% qué cantidad de
la solución salina del 10% usó el
farmacéutico en la mezcla
bueno aquí nos dicen que tenemos una
solución del 10% y del 15% vamos a
asignar las variables vamos a llamar
a la cantidad de la solución salina del
10 por ciento cantidad cantidad
cantidad de él
por ciento
y digamos que f va a ser la cantidad
usada la cantidad del 15%
y nos dice que la suma de la solución
salina del 10% más del 15% nos da 100
mililitros
entonces
efe
deberá ser igual a 100
100 mililitros si yo multiplico punto 1
por t obtendré que tanta salinidad fue
contribuido por esta solución así que
voy a tener 0.1
dt
y si yo multiplico punto 15 por efe voy
a obtener que tanta salinidad fue
aportada por esta solución de el 15 por
ciento entonces más 0.15
efe y esto va a ser igual a la salinidad
que es de la solución final fue del 12%
esto es igual
cuál es el 12% de 100 pues va a ser 12
12 mililitros
y aquí tenemos dos ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas como nos piden la solución t
primero cancelemos de hacer es así que
vamos a multiplicar t más
efe igual a 100 x menos punto 15 voy a
multiplicarlo y lo voy a escribir abajo
en otro color menos punto 15 deporte es
menos punto 15 t
- punto 15 por efe va a ser igual a
menos punto 15 f
y menos punto 15% va a ser igual a menos
15 esto es igual a menos 15
y ahora este 5 se ve muy feo es un 5
vamos a sumar estas dos ecuaciones la
suma de estas dos la voy a escribir aquí
abajo
punto 1 de 2.15 te va a ser igual a
menos
punto 05 dt
punto 15 efe - punto 15 efe pues se
cancelan aquí no escribo nada de hecho
por eso lo hice así 12
15 va a ser igual a menos 3
me queda entonces que menos puntos y 05
dt es igual a menos 3 multiplicamos
ambos lados por menos 1 y me queda que
en punto 0 5 dt es igual a 3
ahora dividimos ambos lados en 3.05 me
va a quedar que t es igual a 3 / 0.05 y
voy a sacar mi calculadora para ver
cuánto es aquí está mi calculadora así
que 3 en 3.05 es igual a 60
esto me es igual a 60 así que de estos
100 mililitros 60 mililitros fueron
aportados por mi cantidad por mi
solución salina del 10 por ciento que es
la opcional esto es algo confuso como
pues que variable usar para la solución
salina del 10% y como establezco la
segunda ecuación para hacer este sistema
de dos ecuaciones y dos incógnitas un
buen lugar es darse cuenta que nos piden
que tanta solución salina del 10% se
aportó y eso me permitió definir esta
variable t y también definir la variable
para el otro tipo de solución y sé que
debemos sumar los para obtener 100
mililitros la parte curiosa fue
establecer qué tanta salinidad
contribuyeron las soluciones de 10 y de
15 para los 12 mililitros de salinidad
del resultado bueno veamos la siguiente
pregunta
la velocidad de manejo promedio de andy
en un viaje de 4 horas fue de 45
kilómetros por hora durante las primeras
tres horas él condujo a 40 kilómetros
por hora
cuál fue su velocidad promedio en la
última hora de viaje este es un problema
de distancia igual a rapidez por el
tiempo vamos a escribir la fórmula la
distancia distancia es igual a la
rapidez por el tiempo el promedio de la
rapidez que nos dicen es de 45
kilómetros por hora así que aquí la
rapidez va a ser igual a la distancia
entre el tiempo nos dicen que el
promedio de rapidez es de 45 kilómetros
así que hacer 45 es igual a la distancia
entre el tiempo y el tiempo nos dicen
que fueron 4 horas así que estas cuatro
horas aquí podemos calcular la distancia
vamos a despejar la distancia distancia
es igual a 45 por 4 45 por 4 es igual
a 180 km
esta es la distancia total eso fue lo
que recorrió en su viaje y nos preguntan
cuál fue su velocidad promedio durante
la última hora de viaje aquí tenemos que
ver cuánta distancia le quedaba por
cubrir en las primeras tres horas
condujo a 40 kilómetros por hora 40
kilómetros por hora a qué velocidad o
con qué rapidez viajo para cubrir 60
kilómetros en la hora restante en las
primeras tres horas él condujo a 40
kilómetros por hora así que la distancia
la distancia de las primeras tres horas
fue igual a 40
kilómetros por hora por hora
por tres horas por tres horas estas
horas se van tres por cuatro doce igual
a 120 kilómetros esto recorrió durante
las primeras tres horas que viajó a 40
kilómetros por hora si durante las
primeras tres horas recorrió 120 y el
total fueron de 180 180 menos 120 menos
120 es igual a 60 kilómetros le faltaban
recorrer 60 kilómetros en la última hora
de viaje a qué velocidad o con qué
rapidez viajo para cubrir 60 kilómetros
en una hora restante pues fue a 60
kilómetros por hora
la respuesta es 60 kilómetros por hora
qué es la opción de
esta opción es te pareció un problema
complicado pero el truco de recordar que
la distancia es igual a la rapidez por
el tiempo y reconocer que en este
segundo enunciado que durante las
primeras tres horas él condujo a 40
kilómetros nos estaban diciendo cuánto
viajó las primeras tres horas y en el
primer enunciado nos estaban diciendo la
distancia total que recorrió y ahí
podemos saber qué tan rápido viajó en la
última hora veamos el último problema
una tubería puede llenar un tanque en 20
minutos mientras otra tarda 30 minutos
en llenar el mismo tanque que tanto
tardarán ambas tuberías para llenar
juntas el mismo tanque
a expresar esto como la primera tubería
que no es lo mismo que llena un tanque
por eso lo pongo te de tanque
en 20 minutos 20 minutos
mi segunda tubería de subíndice 2 va a
llenar el mismo tanque este mismo tanque
pero lo va a llenar en 30 minutos 30
minutos
que tanto tardarán las tuberías
combinadas en llenar este mismo tanque
eso lo podemos expresar como uno entre
por el tanque por minuto entre minuto
más
uno entre 30
igual por tanque por minuto
esto es igual sacamos el común
denominador que es 60 60
esto es 3
i
de tanque o por tanque / minutos
que es igual 325 entre 60 tanque por
minuto y si dividimos entre entre 5 nos
va a quedar
12 55 es 1 esto es 55 es 160 entre 5 es
12 y nos va a quedar que es
doceavo por tanque por minuto
lo que es igual a que se va a llenar un
tanque en 12 minutos si usamos ambas
tuberías que es mi opción de esta es mi
respuesta correcta y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo